بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول الله
تعالى في كتابه الكريم انزل من السماء ماء
فسالت اوديه
بقدرها فاحتمل السيل زبدا
الرابيه ومما يوقدون عليه في النار ابتغاء
حليه او متاع زبد
مثله ذلك يضرب الله الحق
والباطل فاما الزبد فيذهب
جفاء واما ما ينفع الناس فيمكث في
الارض كذلك يضرب الله
الامثال للذين استجابوا لربهم
الحسنى والذين لم يستجيبوا له لو ان لهم
ما في الارض جميعا ومثله معه لافتدوا به
اولئك لهم سوء سء الحساب وماواهم جهنم
وبئس
المهاد في هذه الايه الله سبحانه وتعالى
يضرب
مثلا للحق
والباطل ويضرب
مثلا ل
القران
حين ما تطرا هذه الايات وهذا
الوحي على اوديه القلب قلب
الانسان
وال الشهوات والاوساخ التي تكون في قلوب
الناس
كذلك
ف هذه
الايه الله سبحانه وتعالى يمثل
لنا
حقيقه وجود الحق ومكوث الحق في
الارض وكذلك اضمحلال
الباطل وان
ظهر وكانه باق فهو
ذاهب وان ظهر الباطل
وكانه
سيدوم فهو سرعان
ما يذهب
وينسى قال تعالى انزل من السماء
ماء الماء
هنا
مثل
للقران
والوحي ان الله سبحانه تعالى كما انزل من
السماء ماء
حسيا فانزل من السماء ماء
معنويا وذلك
ما يغيث به سبحانه وتعالى
الروح فقال تعالى انزل من السماء ماء
فسالت اوديه بقدرها يعني كل واد على
قدره بعض
الاوديه اكبر من بعض بعض الاوديه اصغر
واضيق من بعض وكذلك
القلوب بعض
القلوب
اوسع من بعض وبعض القلوب اضيق من
بعض فكذلك كل
قلب يحتمل من هذا الماء على
قدره وكذلك
الوحي والله انزل من السماء ماء
فكل واد يسيل
بقدره فكذلك انزل سبحانه وتعالى القران
والوحي
والايمان
فحينما يطرا هذا الوحي على القلب فكل قلب
بحسبه بعض هذه القلوب
اوسع فتحمل من
العلم زياده على ما
تحمل القلوب
الاخرى يقول اوديه بقدرها فاحتمل السيل
زبدا رابيه
الزبد هي
الاوساخ التي
تكون على
الارض فحينما ياتي
السيل فهذا الزبد يعلو وينتفخ على فوق
السيل
واحيانا ينتفخ هذا
الزبد وهذا الغثاء وهذه
الرغوه ينتفخ فوق السيل حتى يستر للناظر
كل السيل ما ما يرى الا
هذا هذه
الرغوه لكن هذا في
الظاهر وفي الحقيقه
السيل هو الذي
يبقى وكذلك الصراع بين الحق
والباطل فاحيانا ياتي الباطل
وينتفخ وكانه سيبقى
وكانه ويتعاظم في عين الناظم وكانه اكبر
واعظم واست
للحق ويشوه الحق
لكن سرعان ما
يدمغه الحق فيذهب جفاء واما ما ينفع الناس
فيمكث في
الارض يقول تعالى زبدا رابيا الرابي يعني
ال المنتفخ
العالي ومما يوقدون عليه في النار ابتغاء
حليه او متاع زبد
مثله هذا الان مثل المثل الاول انتهى
المثل
الثاني المثل
الناري المثل الاول مثل
مائي وكثيرا ما يجمع الله سبحانه
وتعالى بينهما في كتابه في الامثله ياتي
بالمثل المائي والمثل
الناري
وهنا يقول تعالى في المثل
الناري ومما يوقدون عليه في في النار
ابتغاء حليه او متاع زبد
مثله
كذلك
تشاهد هذا
الزبد يتعالى
على المعدن الذي يدخل في
الكير فان الحديد له خبث
وخبث الحديد لا
يمكن ان نطهر الحديد منه حتى ندخله في
الكير وكل ما اشتد حر هذا
الكير يشتد
تطهير هذا الحديد وهذا
المعدن لكن
لما
هذا هذا المعدن من الذهب او فضه او
نحاس او حديد او ما شابه ذلك اما لمتاع
واما لزينه على حسب
المعدن هذه المعادن
تختلف
في مصالح الناس منها وكذلك تختلف في
حقيقتها لكن كلها السبيل الى تطهيرها
ماذا
النار
الكير
وهذا
يلفت النظر
والانتباه الى ما سبق في بدايه
السوره الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول يسقى بماء
واحد ونفضل بعضه على بعض في
الاكل هذه المعادن متلف والنبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
يقول الناس معادن كمعادن الذهب
والفضه خيارهم في الجاهليه خيارهم في
الاسلام اذا فقه هكذا يقول صلى الله عليه
وسلم
المعدن يختلف هل الذهب افضل من النحاس
الجواب
باعتبار باعتبار الزينه قد يكون باعتبار
مصالح اخرى
لا الذهب لا يغني عن النحاس والذهب لا
يغني عن الفضه وكذلك النحاس لا يغني عن
الحديد الحديد لا يغني عن الذهب
والعكس
كذلك والذهب لا يغني عن
الحديد قد يكون هذا مطلوب طوبا اكثر من
هذا لدى الناس وقد يكون هذا اعلى جوده
وهذا اندر من هذا لكن هذا لا
يسد مسد هذا وكذلك الناس الناس
يختلفون تجد في الناس العالم
وال الشجاع وتجد في
الناس الذكي والفطن تجد في الناس
كل الناس يختلفون لو كان كل الناس على نفس
المستوى من الذكاء فسدت الارض الارض ما
تمشي كذلك لو كان الناس كلهم على نفس
القوه كلهم على
نفس ما يمكن للانسان ان يفلح هكذا
والناس حتى تستقيم مصالحهم في هذه الدنيا
فضل بعضنا على
بعض فعلى كل
حال هذه المعادن السبيل الى تطهيرها سبيل
واحد وهو الحراره فالله تعالى يقول ومما
يوقدون عليه وفي قراءه ومما توقدون عليه
في النار ابتغاء حليه او متاع زبد مثله
مشابه للزبد الذي يعلو
السيل الله سبحانه وتعالى مثل
القران وما ينزله من الوحي بالماء بالغيث
الذي ينزله من
السماء فهل كذلك الكير هو مثل
ايضا للقران نقول
لا بل الظاهر ان الله سبحانه وتعالى يجمع
بين هذين كثيرا في
القران الوحي كالغيث من
السماء والنار
والحراره
ك المصائب والصعوبات التي يواجهها الانسان
في حياته فاذا اجتمع هذا الى
هذا تم الفوز باذن
الله النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول اشد
الناس بلاء الانبياء ثم الامثل فالامثل
ال علم لا يغني
الوحي لا يغني عن
الابتلاء كذلك الابتلاء لا يطاق الا
بالعلم
والايمان فالله سبحانه وتعالى ينزل العلم
والايمان وايضا
يبتلي لانه سبحانه
وتعالى يخرج هذه المعادن بانزال الوحي
ويطهر هذه المعادن
بالابتلاء فمثل سبحانه
وتعالى القران
بالماء
بالمطر والابتلاء بالكير
والحراره فبحسب
اجتماع هذين على
الانسان تكون درجته من النفاسه والطهاره
على حسب
معدنه اذا زدت الحراره كثير كثير كثير على
معدن لا
يستحمل
يذهب
وكذلك اذا
كان المعدن معدن نفيس جدا وما كان عندك
الحراره الكافيه فانه يبقى فيه
الخبث فلا بد من هذا وهذا
فاذا كان المعدن
نفيسا
فانه لا يزداد
بالحراره الا
تطهيرا فيقول تعالى انزل من السماء ماء
فسالت اوديه
بقدرها فاحتمل السيل زبدا رابيه ومما
يوقدون عليه في النار ابتغاء حليه او متاع
زبد مثله وهذا وهذا الزبد نفسه كيف الباطل
الزبد هنا
ممثل الباطل ممثل
بالزبد الزبد هذه الرغوه التي تعلو على
السيل او تعلو وهذا الذي يخرج من الحديد
حينما تزداد الحراره على الحديد فخب خبث
الحديد يبدا
يطلع يكون بشكل هذا
الزبد فهذا
الزبد يوهم الناظر شيئا غير
الحقيقي الانسان ينظر الى هذا الزبد ويظنه
ظاهرا يظنه ماكث يظنه الى اخره لكن في
الحقيقه صرعان ما يذهب وينسى وكان انه لم
يكن فكذلك
الباطل يتعاظم في بدايه
الامر فيغتر به اصحاب النفوس
الرديئه
و اصحاب الجهل
يغترون بذلك واهل الباطل يغترون بهذا
الباطل الله تعالى يقول ولا يحيق المكر
السيء الا
باهله يخادعون الله والذين امنوا وما
يخدعون الا انفسهم وما
يشعرون اصحاب الباطل يغرون بباطل وكل واحد
منهم يظن ان الباطل تبعه يختلف عن باطل
غيره كل واحد منهم يظن ان ذكائه يختلف عن
ذكاء غيره وان احواله تختلف عن احوال غيره
وان الرخصه تبعته تختلف عن رخصه غيره
وهكذا
هذه من وساوس
الشيطان فيضرب الله هكذا الحق والباطل
يقول تعالى كذلك يضرب الله الحق
والباطل كما ضرب هذه الامثله فكذلك يضرب
الله الحق والباطل الحق
والباطل
يصطدمان يقول تعالى بل نقذف بالحق على
الباطل فيدم
فاذا هو
زاهق هذه الرغوه لا تقوى على السيل هي
تظهر من اجل
الحق بسبب الحق يظهر شيء من الباطل لكن
سرعان ما
يذهب
وكذلك الباطل لا يقوم بذاته ويقوم على
غيره والا فهو ضعيف لا يستطيع
ليست له حقيقه ذاتيه وانما هي توهم
الحقيقه
والعظمه فهو يقول كذلك ضرب الله الحق
والباطل فاما
الزبد الباطل
فيذهب جفاء
الزبد الباطل الشهوات التي تك في القلوب
حينما جريان هذا السيل في الاوديه كل واد
بقدره فكذلك
هذه المياه تنظف
وتطهر هذه
الاوديه هذا الزبد نتيجه
هذه الخبائث التي
تكون فتذهب
وكذلك الالام التي تكون اوقات
المصائب هذا الزبد هذه الالام وهذه الص
بات وهذه الاحوال التي يستشعر بها الانسان
حين يبتليه
الله فانه حين ما ينفك عنه الابتلاء ويذهب
وكانه لم
يكن فاما الزبد فيذهب
جفاءه يقول تعالى واما ما ينفع الناس
فيمكث في الارض المعدن الباقي يمكث في
الارض وكذلك طهاره الاوديه وكذلك المياه
الجاريه المجموعه في هذه الاوديه هذه تنفع
الناس
فحينئذ هذه تبقى في الارض والله سبحانه
وتعالى يكتب البقاء
لهذه وكذلك المثال كما يقول ابن عباس رضي
الله
عنهما مثال اليقين والشك والايمان
والنفاق فكذلك
اليقين والايمان والنيه
الصالحه ينفع هذا الناس يمكث في الارض
يبقى
يخلد
واما هذه الاباطيل فانها تذهب سرعان ما
تذهب يقول تعالى فيمكث في الارض كذلك يضرب
الله الامثال وكذلك الحال مع الناس الناس
معاد فكل بحسبه لذلك السفر سمي
سفرا ابتلاء السفر ابتلاء الانسان
يسافر نوع من الابتلاء سمي سفرا لانه يسفر
عن حقيقه المسافر حقيقه بتطلع في السفر
السفر اللي هو
البيان التوضيح حقيقته
تتضح
فالناس كلما اشتد عليهم الحار الحرب فكذلك
معدن الشخص
يظهر يظهر المعدن
الحقيقي يقول تعالى كذلك يضرب الله
الامثال المؤمن لا يزداد الابتلاء الا
ايمانا والمنافق لا يزداد بالابتلاء
الا
نفاقا والكافر لا يزداد بالابتلاء وبوحي
كفرا
وهكذا فكل على حسب معدنه وكل واد على قدره
نكتفي بهذا القدر والله صلى الله وسلم على
نبينا
محمد 17
سهر chapter قران الله سبحانه وتعالى is
giving an example of truth and
falsehood he gives two examples two para
two anies for truth
andal as we before the begin chapter
‏ch سه
الران
main points three
main
سفر تحيد الله سبحانه
وتالى
محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
wor
second on the hearts of
man and
so اللهانه
وتالى
‏fruits as
this الله سبحانه وتعالى gives
exy of his revelation and the difference
in the hearts of men he mentions that
the first analy he sends down from the
heavens from above
‏water and each
valy begins to
flow based on the
size each valley is different some
valleys are wider some valleys are
deeper
etc likewise val here in this
analy the val are analogous to the
hearts of men
‏people are of
different different hearts some have
deeper and some have more shallow hearts
based on this each will carry of the
revelation of allah in his
heart the appropriate الله سبحانه
وتعالى and as rivers begin flow we see a
devel on to of the on to of the stream
‏this that
develops this is the river bed
being purified
from by the water as it flows down it
this thats to devel on
to starts to devel on
to the
flowing this is an
‏that heart
قران theirs and raise the to the
to another
analy
‏s can be witnessed on
to
of a metal a precious metal that is
being purified in a
furnace take gold or silver or steel or
whatever it is and it's put
into a furn we to
sim to devel that isin of that
‏that
we
theam now
this and this analogy the second analogy
some of the scholars mention it is
redundant of the first analogy me the
same thing just in a different light
others mention
that the analogy of the water is the
analy of revelation and the analy of the
fire is the analy of tribulation
‏person
trib الله سبحانه
وتالى to a
a those of pure origins or pure
ence the h the
fant
butf
‏the the it will could dy or permanently
damage
these
these lesser mets and so a person is t
by allah
revelation and
experiences
tribulation in this world
‏and as these things collect in a person
heart they will either become better and
consistently become better or they will
become worse based on their essence who
they are الله سبحانه
وتالى الله
clash the truth and
faleh as for the it is quickly disc
‏the is
exed
truth fai
belief these
things
they have a long term irreversible
effect
as
‏over as
over الله سبحانه وتالى men the
parable of tru and fal
that
preoccupy that gathered on to of that
stream
gather bur
metal disc
‏qui
as
that
in allah
doke
tr اعلم صلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين
[Silence]
‏e
ان